this week convict zone is in Munich at
the annual security conference and my
guest is the foreign minister of Lebanon
Gibran Basile his streets are groaning
with rubbish he's coping with the influx
of 2 million refugees and near total
political paralysis is Lebanon about to
become another failed state
for Minister Gibran Bastille
welcome to conflict zone thank you your
prime minister warned last year that
Lebanon risks becoming a failing state
even the most basic services now don't
get provided to people how did you get
so bad I wouldn't call Lebanon the
failed state when he was able to cope
with fifty percent of his population as
refugees to 100 Syrian displaced to
Lebanon per square kilometer I wonder
that he said last October I warned we
are moving towards collapse if matters
continue yeah but when when solid states
and successful states like in Europe
were not able to receive more than
10,000 refugees and Lebanon got adapted
with one and a half million
I wouldn't we have a very successful
model that if it fails our model of
diversity and coexistence then
everything will fail it's not successful
when you can't even cope with the
rubbish on the streets you can't it will
clear the rubbish you can't blame the
refugees for that you know but this is
this is our responsibility I cannot deny
it but still this is a system that has
become the activists say so inefficient
and corrupt that it can't provide basics
and depends how you how you measure the
success of a society you can have a
democracy and a prosperity but no
cohesion and a society so everything
gets the same degraded society that
country the rubbish and can't clear the
air for its people and puts their health
in danger shouldn't be governing [ __ ]
I'm not defending this but I'm saying
you have also political garbage and you
have the war garbage that you are
witnessing everywhere and I think this
is still less costly than having to
dealing people as garbage and killing
them like when we have 200,000 kills per
people and in Syria and in the region we
are enforcing it I understand but a
government that cannot provide basic
services isn't worthy of the name of
government is it why don't you resign
because if I find somebody who can clear
the Rye you are you are right on this
but the problem is that we have vacancy
and you stay there we cannot resign we
are obliged to stay because there will
be no government there will be complete
vote and in Lebanon if we resign stay
and gamble with the health of your
people no no where we should elect a
president who should be representative
of his people a strong president with
strong popularity and then we will have
another governor instead there are feuds
infighting manipulation and you say this
is a model of cooperation this is a
model of coexistence this is a model of
political paralysis our vertical
paralysis I'm not talking of cooperation
I'm talking of coexistence because in
Lebanon somehow Muslims and Christians
are still living together in a
power-sharing model and parity where
this does not exist anywhere else in the
world and Sunnis and Shias despite all
the tension around us I'll still not
fighting in Lebanon and there's no
leadership and there's no decisions yes
this is from the central bank governors
kind also of the paralysis that we have
in the whole region because in Lebanon
that is somehow reflected in politics
this who this will of eliminating the
other to play your part of the system
the system was broken down completely
I'm not there denying our global and
collective responsibility we have a
responsibility inside our country and we
have the responsibility of the world who
is interfering in our country and not
letting things go as per the mocker and
mean we Russians we preach the democracy
and we don't allow the most
representative people to come and govern
and rule without corruption yes we have
corruption in our country but this is
why we need to have strong leaders to
fight corruption corruption and
different factions playing politics yes
with a nation that can ill afford it I
mean even the patriarch spoke of the
erosion of your state institutions at
the moment
of course collapsing the states
collapsing it depends how doing how you
define the collapse we still have at
least a family in Lebanon we still have
values values of how we live how we
think towards the other where this is
fading completing other parts even in
strong and prosperous countries you
don't see this kind of cohesion that we
still have a Lebanon president in a few
years what cohesion is that almost 35
attempts to get a quorum in Parliament
you haven't managed to do it you haven't
passed the budget since 2005 you have a
parliament whose mandate ran out in 2013
and had to extend it twice without
recourse to the public you haven't had
legislative elections since 2009 yes
everywhere I guess is complete paralysis
of the political bodies and we are
against all this but you're not doing
much about that defend me against I'm
not defending the politics in Lebanon
the politicians nor the minister you're
wondering I'm defending something that
belongs to all of us in humanity I'm
defending the idea and the model that we
study present of diversity of living
together of accepting each other where
we are different this is what I'm
defending and this is where I'm saying
the importance of Lebanon if we have
this model versus the model of - what do
you choose you choose the raca model
with - or you still have Lebanon where
people can still live together because
what else can you get so we can get the
- model notice that how much of this
living together was apparent when you
see the people protests on the streets
of Lebanon as I have done over the last
year and they get subjected to
unacceptable violence by the security
services water cannon teargas but you're
in rubber bullets you know I was among
the protesters I was of violence I went
myself to the street because I refused
the situation so who's in charge in
charge we are we are in jail they're in
jail of power because we cannot leave
again you're a government that doesn't
control your security services
what you're telling me no stand even
with the security level we are still
fine if we compare us to other regions
other countries around us in the region
so again it is a situation that we have
to fix how by not imposing a solution
that is a ready solution already a
recipe by allowing the Lebanese let let
them go to elections and allow them to
truly 11 have elections we pointed out
since 2009 because your prime minister
said the levels of force used against
demonstrators was unacceptable
he's the Prime Minister can t do
anything about this yes he stopped it
but who was prosecuted I'm telling you I
was prosecuted I was myself on the
street no but who are you three times
for the excesses because I refused the
situation
Minister you refused the situation but
people got beaten up people got
hospitalized
dozens of people were taken the hospital
people let's not portray Lebanon as a
country where you don't allow people to
express themselves we have an excess of
democracy and in Lebanon and people are
allowed to speak out whatever your
security I guess I chose out to discuss
all this happen
this happened again Lebanon is the bacon
of freedoms in the region and this
happened once we don't take this
incident and extrapolate it on our
Minister daily laughs can you claim to
be a beacon of freedom when the
allegations of torture carried out by
your security services are widespread
June last year there was a leaked video
showing members of your internal
security forces torturing inmates in
Rumia prison north of Beirut the
Interior Minister confirmed that the
video was authentic this is the kind of
beacon of tolerance and coexistence that
you say you have where torture is
widespread Human Rights Watch said this
was just the tip of the ice exception
that confirms the the rule no we don't
have this comment this is an incident
that happened there if you say that this
is what happened in Guantanamo does it
mean that in
the US you live the torture this is an
incident that happened once and that
confirmed that will this is not the case
in you know you know very well minister
know we're admitting this completely
because it is we have so many things
that we are not satisfied about eleven
but we don't turn it into being a place
where people are tortured so why did the
colonists relation the level of life
that we still have the we have a next
Rida mum expression a Lebanon that is
unequal and if what you say is true why
did the Committee Against Torture note
in November in a report to the Human
Rights Council that torture is being
used routinely they said by your armed
forces and law enforcement agencies it
spoke of a clear pattern of widespread
torture and ill-treatment of suspects in
custody we refused this completely you
think they make it up in the end this no
they base it on an incident and I'm
telling you again
widespread every day there are protests
in Lebanon and nobody is beaten it
happened you say it happened once and
twice and an out of 100 but this is not
this is this is not normal we condemn it
we refuse it we are working not to allow
it to happen but in a situation where we
have word around us where we have you
know we have extremist an excuse which
which way is it we have it spoke of a
clear pattern of widespread torture and
ill-treatment of suspects in custody
especially Syrians and Palestinians
serious yes Alice tinea yes which
country tell me which country was able
to show the hospitality and the
generosity that we showed more than 40
percent of our knowledge talking about
no it's working it's not not a hot water
we are listening them in our places in
our homes we are giving them our
services and no country showed the
generosity that so UN Committee against
Iran is now King nonsense no not Susan
there is no there is no one country can
you tell me it is known so no can you
tell me can you tell me tell me please a
country in Europe that can receive 200
refugees per square kilometer
and not taking any measures we did not
close our borders we did not take any
measures nobody I guess just torturing
we're by the torture carried on by your
service the Syrians and the Palestinians
we are we are toast we are hosting the
Palestinians since 65 years in Lebanon
in November you had the worst terror
attack in Beirut since the end of the
Civil War 43 people died in attacks this
will continue in Lebanon wanted because
you have a whole array of terrorist
groupings inside the country that you've
been unable to dislodge haven't you no
we don't agree that this should
necessarily continue because this if it
happened in the France what happened in
the France is wide wide much wider and
bigger than what happened in Lebanon you
have Islamic state no you in do we have
do we have to say that this this should
be a repetition or else we should help a
small country like Lebanon to be more
cohesive against the terrorists you know
you know what you have found astray you
have a little answer you have Abdullah
Azzam brigades you have Fatah al-islam
Fattah al Intifada even Hezbollah says
it's worried by the number of Islamic
States sleeper cells that you have can
you tell me why we are fighting - on our
eastern borders and we did not allow
them to occupy our land and our country
well though we had a text from all
fronts what did we receive as what we
deserve at arms as a small army that is
fighting you know the big I'm not doing
better I'm talking about the number of
terrorist groups that operate on your
territory yes when we are fighting than
you do when you do deals with we will do
deals oh we do the prisoner exchange we
dismantled them you did a terrorist
exchange deal with them you exchange
reason we had our our soldiers kidnapped
there is a victor of parliament said it
was a sovereignty scandal Nabih Berri
said it was a sovereignty scandal
you doing deals with Java thunders we
get got back our livin ease soldiers who
were kidnapped and none of those who
were exchanged was sentenced in Lebanon
it was a sign of weakness wasn't of
course it was it was the sign of
weakness because they were kidnapped
from the very beginning it was the sign
of weakness and this is why we want
strong if you do deals this is what I
kidnap more this is right no yes but
this is why we asked we and we are
asking to have a strong president and
the strong government coming from the
will of the Lebanese people this is why
we want a strong country not to have
weaknesses where terrorists can can
penetrate you know that we had the first
decapitation of a Lebanese officer in
2000 of course we are under threat from
terrorists
of course we are we are on the front
line and we are we are paying the price
for all terrorism but do we deserve to
be helped or to be accused you are
leader of the free patriotic movement
among your political allies you can't
Hezbollah which is regarded by many in
the world including all the other Arab
governments incidentally as a terrorist
group are you senior US official said
last year that Hezbollah is responsible
for perpetrating terrorism and
fermenting instability worldwide you
claim to be fighting terrorism
why are you allied then with a group
that is apparently responsible for
perpetrating terrorists you know you
have to no effect that Hezbollah in
Lebanon represents the third of our
population we cannot acute the third of
the Lebanese to be terrorists and we
cannot say that husband is a coup so you
can turn a blind eye to turned on so we
don't turn blind and we say they are not
we refuse the accusation so the other
Arab states are wrong America's wrong
you're gay why because Hezbollah is
fighting Israel and you know Israel
can't put the blame that's the only
reason why it's labeled as a terrorist
as is
movement of resistance against the
occupiers of Lebanon and now he is
fighting the terrorists who are - and
the nostril how come you do disarm
Minister in the Arab world who's
prepared to give his Bella political
backing I'm not the only ones you are
the only one who refused to sign a
document I know I don't label them as a
terrorist group of course you're the
only one not refused our Lebanon is
united on this you should know this
Lebanon is you will learn and you know
you're not in front of the terrorists
you will not find one Lebanese
describing husband s terrorist because
husband the freed our country from an
occupation which is Israel and because
husband now is fighting the terrorists
so this is something that all the
Lebanese are united we usually missing
term we agree its purpose we agree you
know we disagree with husband on many
things internal politics and external
politics we don't agree we are we want
officially to disassociate Lebanon from
the crisis in Syria we don't want
husband not to feel the fighting outside
Lebanon we don't want this like this if
has mother doing this does not mean that
we accuse him of Terror at the beginning
of this month
French police reported smashing a cell
of Hezbollah agents accused of
trafficking cocaine America's drug
enforcement agency claimed the drug
profits we used to finance their
fighting in Syria these are your
political allies drug dealing running
drug cartels you proud of them if
Hezbollah are selling drugs of course we
condemn this and we refuse it and we
should take the deal it measures to stop
this but if it is true that's but you're
not going to drop it you're not going to
drop your alliance with Hezbollah
whatever it does are you going to drop
whenever it is proved that Hezbollah as
a terrorist organization and this is the
drug dealer yes we're ready for more
than this to preserve our country this
is what your obsesses again America says
support from us or us what the Lebanese
say you know again they represent the
third of our population they had they
are part of our government they are part
of our
and they have a big block and the big
representation and we are not ready to
sacrifice our national unity and to
preserve our country for the sake of
anybody and all of an accusation yeah
you know of course Israel and many other
countries are bothered with husband
having the ability to face Israel and
there would be such accusations this is
not surprising us what we want is real
facts that we can enable us to say yes
we have to do something about it
but until then well the Drug Enforcement
Agency I'm sure if you are never give
you've let facts let me give you facts
let's look to something we agree on
do we agree that we have all to fight -
as as as a terror group so if we all
agree on this let's focus on this why to
focus on things where we disagree the
major threat now on on all of us and the
extremists like - and the Nostra and and
the world if I was very so difficult
that you are allied with an organization
that they accuse of perpetrating
terrorism that's why the rest of the
world well finds that alliance of yours
so trouble and what do you Accord the
United States and the other European
Union and the p5 plus one who agreed was
Iran on the nuclear deal and did you
call them they made an alliance with
Iran and they are covering Iran for for
covering Hezbollah this if this is the
case you can take you know I'm talking
to you of what you do you do I'm not
talking to the Americans at this moment
you you speak for Lebanon and you don't
speak for the rest of the case it's not
American is we agree with Hezbollah on
something does it mean we agree on
everything the same as the international
community agreed with Iran or something
does it mean they agree on everything I
want to talk briefly before we run out
of time about the refugees the 1.6
million Syrian refugees that you spoke
about also the half a million
Palestinians that you have on yourself
you're on record since 2013 as telling
people not to come to Lebanon you don't
want the Syrians to come you said
Lebanon should not be the garbage dump
for the
world's problems you see refugees as
garbage not at all
you know the the garbage of politics
enough not people and I believe that the
Jo politics are treating the Syrians as
as garbage and we are receiving them we
are taking the problems and we are you
know suffering through the setbacks of
the failure of the global system but
you're making it much harder for the
enemy no not at in February of last year
you tightened your regulation
significantly didn't you Syrians are no
longer permitted entry simply for
seeking international protection are
they no you know that until now not one
Syrian was was forbidden there's a new
regulations issued by your general
Security February 25th why why don't we
raise the question where we did nothing
to forbid the Syrians from coming and
it's our right because it's in our
Constitution that Lebanon is not a place
for implanting Syrians and Palestinians
why don't we ask the question to two
Europeans who are taking measures now
each country by itself you can removing
the discussion and weapon I'm going to
stay with Lebanon with Lebanon have your
right the sovereign right to do this and
we're not doing it you know we are we
are not signatories of the Geneva
Convention still we did not take any
measure where are many countries Western
countries are signatories of the Geneva
Convention and they took measures and
they put a cap on the receiving the
Syrian the Minister you are saying they
are now forming a naval force not to
allow the Syrians to come to you or a
signatory of the UN Convention on the
elimination of discrimination against
women aren't you you are you are a
signatory of that convention and you are
continually reminded to abide by that
convention because women particularly
migrant women have been suffering badly
in Lebanon the committee said that it
had received disturbing documented
reports of migrant workers dying from
unnatural causes falls from tall
buildings suicide and the failure of the
state authorities to investigate that
why why are you failing we have we you
know we have and again we are talking of
some incidents you know in every house
of ours
manone we have women maids well who help
us in our daily life so the rate of
crime among them is much lower than the
rate of crime in Lebanon but incidents
can happen yes they can happen we regret
this to happen you're not investigating
no we are we are
according to the community you ever
investigated and many and you know how
many how many foreign workers killed
Lebanese incident that happened in the
house between and a wife and a husband
and between a father and the mother you
know between a father and the son things
can happen in any semester there's great
concern among the knurled Protection
Agency UNICEF that you have not banned
child marriage in your country and under
Sharia law girls get married that means
be forced into having sex at the age of
nine years oh this is not happening
why are you emerging you to set 18 you
know what's the minimum age for marriage
what are you using
but let me know something you know I'm
Lebanese and I don't know where we are
getting all this um you are portraying a
country where we have a high level of
respect to each other towards the other
where we are coping to respect to
receive all foreigners when the underage
girls are getting married everywhere we
are preaching for tolerance and we are
the model of this you are describing
Lebanon as if it's a place of torture
and discrimination well where is this
what is under went Universal Universal
Periodic Review a United Nations Human
Rights 2,000 years reports of everything
happening everywhere in the world you
don't take an incident as a as a fact
for a daily speaking things that are of
concern to the international community
Minister yeah and they are of concern of
us when they happen exceptionally once
in a year they are of a great concern
what we we don't describe this as a
usual matter and Lebanon we reviews this
completely because we would never heard
of this happening if it is an incident
or an exception how you've been at the
meetings where these issues have been
never even representatives have I've met
since my capacity as my capacity as a
foreign minister this is the first time
I hear this about LaVon this kind of
accusations yes we have on the record
some incident that happened yes we deal
with them we have to do more we always
have to do more we should we should do
more to to turn Lebanon into a place of
peace and love and prosperity and
stability and democracy yes of course
but we are facing all the turmoil around
us all right and I think we deserve more
support not again as a country and as a
state but as a model general we will
keep on on promoting for the sake of a
different Basile thanks very much for
being on conflict zone thank you
you